well obviously we'd rather these strikes
were not taking place they come after
six months of on and off industrial
action which has taken a heavy toll on
the NHS but uh we're relieved that it's
only um a one-day strike of course it
was going to originally be two and also
we're grateful to the RCN for putting in
place a rising number of mitigations
specifically agreed with individual
hospitals in order to protect life and
limb services so um you know we will
cope with today it will be difficult
procedures have been canceled in order
to enable us to manage uh today but the
critical issue now is that the staff
Council meets tomorrow and we hope that
that staff Council will work together
and accept the deal and that we can
finally end this industrial though of
course the junior doctors action is is
still ongoing do you feel these strikes
are Justified
there's no question the the pay and the
real terms pay of NHS uh staff uh has
fallen and there's also no question that
our staff are working in incredibly
challenging circumstances
the leaders that I speak to day in day
out tell me that they've never been as
worried about morale as they are now we
have huge issues about retaining stuff
we we can recruit stuff generally but we
find it difficult to retain them because
of their working experiences they have
so you know there are genuine issues
that underlie this uh industrial action
uh but obviously what we want to do is
to see issues resolved through
negotiation and the other you know big
issue Jane is that is that in the next
few weeks we hope we'll finally see the
long-term Workforce plan that we've been
promised for for months indeed years
because the underlying challenges we
have 120 000 vacancies in the NHS so
um as I've said before even if there
were no strikes even if there were no
trade unions we would still have huge
challenges about recruitment retention
and motivation in our Health Service you
say you want to see these issues
resolved through negotiation the unions
are saying that the health secretary
doesn't seem willing to to get around
the table and talk
well it certainly took too long for this
to happen we had several months at the
beginning of the year when the
government refused to negotiate with the
uh were the NHS trade unions a week
repeatedly for the government to open
negotiation and they finally did so that
was a wasted opportunity but then that
negotiation started when it did start
there was good progress and the
Secretary State played his role in
progress and and that's what culminated
in a deal a deal that most of the
affected staff have accepted and now the
question is whether all the unions will
tomorrow accept this deal and we can
move on but as I say that will still
leave major issues the government needs
to address in terms of Staffing and
Health Service do you think that the
nurses demands are unrealistic
well if it hadn't been for the action
that the nurses the paramedics other
groups took then they wouldn't have had
the pay deal which is going to be
discussed tomorrow
um and that pay deal comprises a fairly
significant backdated some and also five
percent uh for this year so it's been
the togetherness the solidarity of the
NHS trade Unions that's got them the
progress that they have achieved
otherwise they would have had a much
smaller
settlement but I think our view now is
that given that most staff are voted in
favor of this deal it is time to accept
it for the unions to work together
and for us to think more long term about
what we need to do to address you know
that that crisis of 120 000 vacancies in
the Health Service